During the pandemic, many teachers told me that this is the first time...
...they've seen so much parent engagement,...
...and a lot of that is because parents are home listening to the lessons,...
...but also because they are engaging technology...
...that makes it easier for parents to be up to speed.
Not all students can afford the space and internet connection needed to study online,...
...which means increased use of remote learning risks widening the digital divide.
Ultimately, the barrier to success for all EdTech, not just e-education, is financial.
For EdTech to be successful,...
...there needs to be investment in the schools that currently are under-resourced.
There needs to be a push to make sure that these schools have the proper internet access,...
...the facilities and everything else they need to be able to properly function with EdTech.
If that doesn't happen,...
...then we will see inequities develop in the classroom and across schools.